♪ ♪
>> Laura: AND NOW COVID
TRUTHS, FRAUD AND TYRANTS.
FIRST THE TRUTH.
TOLD YOU SEVEN WEEKS AGO THAT
EYE DROPS OF CORBIN IS LIKELY
SAVING LIVES.
NOW ANOTHER STUDY CONFIRMS THAT
CONCLUSION.
IT WAS CONDUCTED BY NYU’S
GROSSMAN SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
WHERE RESEARCHERS LOOKED AT 932
COVID PATIENCE WHO WERE ON A
DRUG’S APARTMENT ALONG WITH ZINC
AND AZITHROMYCIN.
THEY CONCLUDED THAT THE TRIPLE
COMBO, THEY WERE 44% LESS LIKELY
TO DIE FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
GOOD NEWS.
TAKE THAT, FDA.
SECOND PIECE OF GOOD NEWS, THE
TWO STATES THAT OPENED UP FIRST,
FLORIDA AND GEORGIA, BOTH ARE
CONTINUING TO SEE DECLINES IN
COVID INFECTIONS.
WHILE, SHOCKING TO LIBERAL
HATERS, BUT NOT TO YOU, BECAUSE
WE TOLD YOU THAT THE VIRUS WAS
PROBABLY WEAKENING AND THAT
PEOPLE WOULD INNOVATE TO STAY
SAFE.
AND NOW ONTO THE FRAUD.
LET’S START WITH RACHEL LEVINE,
WHO WEEKS AGO ORDERED NURSING
HOMES TO ADMIT COVID-POSITIVE
PATIENCE.
WELL, WHILE THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS SAW THEIR LOVED ONES
AND FAMILY MEMBERS DIE, LEVINE
QUIETLY EXTRACTED HER OWN MOTHER
OUT OF HARM’S WAY.
, REPORTEDLY
MOVING HER FROM A NURSING HOME
TO A HOTEL.
>> MY MOTHER REQUESTED, AND MY
SISTER AND I COME AS HER
CHILDREN, COMPLIED TO MOVE HER
TO ANOTHER LOCATION DURING THE
COVID-19 OUTBREAK.
MY MOTHER IS 95 YEARS OLD, SHE
IS VERY INTELLIGENT, AND MORE
THAN COMPETENT TO MAKE HER OWN
DECISIONS.
>> Laura: I WOULD RATHER HAVE
HER MOTHER BE HEALTH SECRETARY
OF PENNSYLVANIA, FRANKLY.
BUT ONCE AGAIN, LIBERALS LIKE
LEVINE AND HER BOSS, IT’S, YOU
KNOW, IT’S GOOD FOR THE SAME OLD
HYPOCRISY.
THE RULES ARE FOR THEE, BUT NOT
FOR ME.
WHILE THE LITTLE PEOPLE HAVE TO
SUFFER ANOTHER BAD DECISION, THE
CONNECTION THE POWERFUL ALWAYS
HAVE AN ESCAPE PATH, AND THAT’S
WHAT HAPPENED THERE.
AND SWEAR ON THE FRAUD PATROL,
WE HAVE TO POINT OUT ILLINOIS’
OWN STATE HEALTH DIRECTOR WHO AT
A RECENT PRESS CONFERENCE JUST
CASUALLY ADMITTED THIS.
>> IF YOU WERE IN HOSPICE AND
HAD ALREADY BEEN GIVEN, YOU
KNOW, A FEW WEEKS TO LIVE, AND
THEN YOU ALSO WERE FOUND TO HAVE
COVID, THAT WOULD BE COUNTED AS
A COVID DEATH, EVEN IF YOU DIED
OF CLEAR ALTERNATE CAUSE, BUT
YOU HAD COVID AT THE SAME TIME,
IT STILL LIFTED LISTED AS A COVI
DEATH.
>> Laura: OKAY.
AT THE CDC, THE STATE HEALTH
OFFICES IN THESE BLUE STATES, NO
WONDER THE PRESIDENT DOESN’T
TRUST THEIR NUMBERS.
AND BY THE WAY, WHATEVER
HAPPENED TO ONE OF THE WORST FLU
SEASONS ON RECORD?
WIRE THOSE NUMBERS NOT TABULATED
AND ACTUALLY SEGREGATED OUT, NOT
LUMPED IN ALTOGETHER IN SOME
CASES WITH THE COVID THAT’S?
THAT BRINGS US TO OUR TYRANTS,
AND FOR THIS CATEGORY WE STAYED
ILLINOIS BECAUSE BILLY
BILLIONAIRE GOVERNOR J.B.
PRITZKER APPARENTLY THINKS THAT
HE CAN SAVE THE PEOPLE OF HIS
STATE BY THREATENING THEM.
ESPECIALLY IN COUNTIES THAT
DECIDE TO GO THEIR OWN WAY AND
GET BACK TO WORK.
>> THE STATE ALREADY PROVIDES A
LOT OF SUPPORT FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES.
AND SO I WOULD JUST SUGGEST
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO US.
AND I DON’T WANT TO UTILIZE
THOSE.
>> Laura: I’M SURE HE DOESN’T.
MAYBE HE WILL INVITE ALL THE
UNEMPLOYED IN HIS STATE TO LIVE
IN HIS NEW $50 MILLION CARIBBEAN
GETAWAY.
I WILL WAIT FOR THAT.
BUT WHAT WOULD A RUNDOWN OF,
LET’S SAY, GUBERNATORIAL TYRANTS
BE, WHERE WOULD THEY BE WITHOUT
WASHINGTON STATE’S JAY INSLEE?
HE’S DECIDED TO TAKE CUES FROM
CHINA BY EMPOWERING AN ARMY OF
GOVERNMENT CONTACT TRACERS TO
MONITOR YOU.
I MEAN ASSIST YOU, IF YOU GET
SICK.
AND IF YOU RESIST, DON’T WORRY,
THE GOVERNMENT WILL MAKE SURE
YOU HAVE ZERO REASONS TO LEAVE
HOME.
>> IF THEY CAN’T GET A FRIEND TO
DO THEIR GROCERY SHOPPING, WE
WILL HELP GET THEM GROCERIES IN
SOME FASHION.
IF THEY NEED PHARMACEUTICALS TO
BE PICKED UP, WE CAN HELP MAKE
SURE THAT THEY GET THERE
PHARMACEUTICALS.
>> Laura: ISN’T THAT
REASSURING?
AND FINALLY WE SAVED THE LEAST
APPEALING FOR LAST.
MICHIGAN’S GRETCHEN WITLESS
WITMER.
HOW TO PERSUADE YOUR STUDENTS TO
SUPPORT THIS ECONOMY CRUSHING
SHUTDOWN?
ATTACK THE FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS AND CALL THEM BIGOTS.
>> CERTAINLY NOT AN EXERCISE OF
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES WHERE WE
HAVE FREE SPEECH.
THIS IS CALLS TO VIOLENCE.
THIS IS RACIST AND MISOGYNISTIC
MISOGYNISTIC-BASED PROTESTS AND
PERVERSE WAY MAKE IT LIKELY THAT
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE TO STAY IN A
STAY HOME POSTURE.
>> Laura: ARE YOU JUST
CLAMBERING TO HAVE HER HEARTBEAT
AWAY FROM THE PRESIDENCY?
OR MAYBE AS YOUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL, WON’T THAT BE A FUN
WORLD TO LIVE IN?
NOW, ANY OF THESE BLUE STATES
CONTROL FREAKS, WELL, ALL OF
THEM, THEY NEED TO KEEP AWAY
FROM OUR CHILDREN AND AWAY FROM
OUR BUSINESSES.
HECK, I DON’T WANT THEM NEAR MY
DOGS AT THIS POINT GIVEN WHAT
THEY’VE BEEN SAYING AND DOING.